Well, now I'm being tricky because 240 is in here and that's not going to be an
integer standard deviation away from the mean. It's like 1.5 standard deviations
from the mean approximately. So then, how are we suppose to calculate the area
under this curve between negative infinity and this non-integer number standard
deviation Deviations from the mean. Well, we can guess that it'll be between
approximately 84 percent and 97.5 percent. 'Because we know that this is 68
percent between here and here. 13.5 percent here, and 2.5 % here, so there'll be
approximately 84 % of values between negative infinity and 226. Another way to
look at it is since it's symmetrical, you know that 50% is less than the mean,
and you know that 34 % is between the mean and one standard deviation. So 84 %
have less than 226 Facebook friends. If we add this section which is 13.5 % then
we know that 97.5 % Are between negative infinity and 262. So, let's' call the
proportion p. We know that p has to be greater than 0.84, and less than 0.975.
But we're going to use a tool that will help us figure out, for any value, what
proportion will this be.